we have new information this morning
about president biden's brother james
biden and foreign business transactions
that were flagged by american banks a
republican senator looking into business
deals made by hunter biden that's the
president's son says james biden played
a key role the senator spoke to our
senior investigative correspondent
catherine herridge
cbs news has learned that more than 150
transactions involving either hunter or
james biden's global business affairs
were flagged as concerning by u.s banks
for further review some of those
concerns including large wire transfers
you just got to make sure you got all
the evidence after nearly a three-year
investigation republican senator chuck
grassley told cbs news he believes the
president's younger brother james was
instrumental in hunter biden's chinese
business ventures i think james biden
was very much a part of this james biden
has worked as an entrepreneur and
recently in the health care industry we
will focus on james biden the
president's brother
this week grassley released bank records
indicating james biden's company the
lion hall group was paid directly by a
chinese finance consulting firm and
these are records that come directly
from the banks no third party yes that's
absolutely right in our interview
grassley did not allege the bidens broke
the law but he said it's concerning that
both hunter and james biden were
promised retainers for their china work
totaling 165 thousand dollars a month in
2017 after joe biden left the vice
presidency we have people with a biden
name dealing with chinese business
people that have a relationship through
the communist party i think it's very
concerning this 2019 subpoena verified
by cbs news shows federal investigators
also sought hunter and james biden's
business records from a major u.s bank
dating back to 2014. multiple sources
tell cbs news the probe by the u.s
attorney in delaware is exploring
whether the younger biden and his
associates potentially violated tax laws
as well as money laundering and foreign
lobbying rules harry littman is a former
federal prosecutor you're working a
serious financial case when you're
sending out that kind of subpoena the
president of public citizen a non-profit
government watchdog said potential
conflicts are found on both sides of the
aisle the hunter-biden relationship
with these chinese firms
is problematic i think any elected
official who's raising concerns about
hunter biden should have been screaming
about what president trump did when he
refused to divest his own business
interest
weissman is referring to former
president trump's decision to maintain
ownership of his global businesses but
hand off control to his two sons china
awarded ivanka trump's fashion brand new
trademarks while she was a senior
advisor to her present father separately
the white house chief of staff said this
week that president biden is confident
his family did the right thing adding
these actions by hunter and james biden
are private matters and don't involve
the president cbs news began outreach to
james and hunter biden's legal teams
last week and received no response nate
catherine thank you